because your abdomen is just
full of lamp lymph nodes and they don't
there's
they go i don't know but they go along
the blood vessels
uh the blood vessels are attached to the
heart the lymph isn't attached to any
pump at all
the lymph is moved by your movement
right and so the lymph is really the
um you know that's the sweeping
mechanism
mechanism of the body to clean out all
the toxins and so
i lost that on my left side
but that went really well and i was
getting better
for a little while
but then i started my feet started to
swell
and then my lower legs started to swell
and so we called the hospital
and talked to the nurses on the unit
that i had stayed on that i had my
surgery on
and they said well you know you've had a
very major surgery it's no wonder that
you might have some swelling
and it was we were like oh okay it seems
extreme but
okay and so then i went to my six-week
appointment
and uh my off my uh post doc
opposed were looking like you were
pregnant on one side or was it a
bulb or what no it was my feet
especially my left foot were swollen up
my lower legs were swollen
up my thighs were swollen up
on one side or both i was filling up
with fluid
right i was filling up with fluid there
was a leak in my abdomen
there was a leak in the lymph nodes so
all of my
fluids from my body were leaking into my
abdominal cavity
and then accumulating
in my body it would be as if there's a
hole in one of the pipes in your body
and the exact pipes are where the limps
yeah except for the lymph is like a
spider web that's how small it is
very very very very impossible thing to
to work with and they had tried to close
off
every i mean they had to take it all out
so they had to close off every little
spider web
and they missed one there's a surprise
okay yeah
and you know the lymph they've they've
done a lot of work
with hearts and the lymph around the
heart
and they get leaks sometimes and they
really know how to fix it
but a leak in the abdomen is something
that is
because they weren't doing radical
surgeries you know what you used to hear
oh someone's got cancer
oh it's in their lymph they're gonna die
right that's what you'd hear
when i was young anyway that's what you
would hear now they can take out the
lymph
which is radical they didn't do that
and to and to have that go well
you know i don't know what the chances
are for it to go well
anyway it didn't go well for me and i
was in the hospital
twice the first time was when they
was when i went in and my limbs were all
full of fluid
and they drained off my abdomen and
they put a they put a shunt into my
abdomen and they drained
off i can't remember something like
seven liters
of fluid what would be the prognosis of
this
death as well well they didn't know what
it was until they drained it off
one of the oncologists told me he
thought i had cancer the liver
or cancer of the peritoneum in the
the uh abdominal cavity which didn't
sound good
yeah that's not pleasant to hear
especially if you didn't do a test and
he's speculating well it could be
cancer off your liver i know i've had
that i've had that happen often
i'm kind of getting used to doctors
doing that i think you do
well if you've had my history of health
problems then you
get used to doctors randomly
suggesting things that they don't have
any reason to suggest
anyway when they when they took off all
this fluid it was milky colored
which is the proper color for fluid from
the lymph
because the lymph picks up fat
and the white color of milk is is fat
so it looked like milk there was no
blood in it there was no
so it wasn't cancerous it was fluid
from my lymph system but a lot of fluid
so it was really pouring out of me um
people who are with me probably know how
much was flowing out of me but
it was it's hard for me to remember it
was just
i had a i had are you on medication or
were you just so out of it because
i think i was on medication i was on
morphine
for quite a bit of the time um and they
may have
put me on morphine when they put the bag
in
to keep me comfortable because it wasn't
comfortable
okay so then it would have been it was
kind of foggy for me
to know how how much i was losing a day
but
a nurse used to come to my house once
they sent me home
she would come at noon and drain off a
liter of fluid
a day and i was still very uncomfortable
i still was you know when i
before i started draining i looked like
i was seven months pregnant
now now it was still kind of a
pregnant look but wasn't as extreme
but i wasn't giving my lymph the
rest it needed to heal because there was
so much
fluid there were doctors that speculated
that if i didn't have any fluid in my
abdomen
if i drained off all the fluid that it
would dry
and then it would possibly heal because
that does happen sometimes that's an
aside where's this fluid coming from
because in a regular person when i say
regular i mean
someone doesn't have this issue yeah
they there's some
there's some uniform in their
distribution of fluid
now yours is pooling and then it's
leaving so is it getting replaced
so then that means it was taken from
some other part of your body to be
placed in your abdomen
i was eating and i was getting thinner
and thinner i took a picture of myself
in one day and i thought
i had no body fat left at all my my
scapulas were sticking off my back my
breasts had lost all the
uh all of the everything was gone
my bum was gone my breasts were gone
my cheeks were gone they were sunken
like i was
down to 90 pounds so i'd lost 30 pounds
probably
and i was getting desperate
and i was also not only was i on
it turned out not only was i on morphine
but because all my bodily fluids were
running out of me i was becoming
malnourished
and so my thought processes were getting
confused
but i was at home with everybody trying
to help me but it was really hard to
know
what to do because the doctors didn't
know what to do here was this
this woman she had a hole in her lymph
in her abdomen and we can
and they couldn't find it they looked i
had so many scans of different so at
this point they're simply draining you
and you can't continue like this for
much longer
um or did they tell you yeah i recall
you saying i don't think i could they
said you could live like this and you
thought hey that's fine i can live like
this
well i could when i i got a t
when i went in for the five weeks
which was right before i finally got
better they changed
i didn't eat anymore at this point now
they put a
picc line near my heart and they fed me
tpn which is a nutrition that you feed
people who can't use their digestive
system anymore
and you can live like that people do
live like that for 25 years
they live like that so a lot of people
what they do is they get nutrition at
night when they're sleeping
and in the day they don't eat anything
they get all their nutrition right
straight to their heart
and so what happened if you were to eat
um well what have what they thought with
me was if they
didn't go through the lymph system that
maybe it would get better but it didn't
and so for five weeks we were trying to
heal it
in ways that wouldn't be cutting me open
again
and we weren't able to find anything
that worked
so by the time i had been in the
hospital for five weeks
i was awake again because now i was
getting nutrition
that's when i started to pray right
that's when you started i thought
you said that you started with queenie
queenie came to give you something
that's when queenie when i was in the
hospital for the last time this five
weeks
see my my electrolytes went out of
balance and i went into emergency
because my potassium was out of whack
and then you're going to have a heart
attack and that was going to be the end
of me
i had lost so many body fluids that my
electrolytes were going out of whack and
that's when you have a heart attack and
die
so i was i was nearly dead but not quite
when i got into the hospital and then
they pumped me full of
fluids until i was my electrolytes
balanced
and then they gave me a tpn diet until
i had enough nutrients for my brain to
turn back on and when that happened i
had been in the hospital for three or
four days
that's when queenie came to the hospital